welcome to boom sorry welcome to this
video playing gloaty phone the doctor
home from Argentina I he'll tell me the
Dutch let's see what light up the stone
wall yeah I'm committed to Knight f3
already and the Sun makes us stonewalled
somewhat more attractive to play Queenie
7mm now I'm playing in a rather
conservative fashion here preparing
Bishop a three year yeah there are many
possible set up against the stone wall
but not as really am yeah close to two
worm yeah refuting this opening it is
some is a play we'll set up some black
maybe even be five now could be
interesting gaining space on the
queenside
you have this exchange of the dark
squared bishop is of course in general a
desirable thing for white and the
question is should i take two should i
take with the Queen Oh with the night
I'm sure not sure maybe night takes us
better but okay this is not bad I mean
the night on a three looks strange but
it actually has a very good I'm REE
routing night c 2 e 1 d 3 this is what
the night is usually doing in this
positions let's see maybe start with the
smooth protecting seafoam and 95 is a
possible follow up if you place bishop a
six now I go 95 aren't interesting yeah
well before certainly not bad for me
Bishop a6 I have be 5a I have this b5
idea no but i usually don't have in this
type of position this he basically gave
me for free after going with going a
fall yeah I threatening b5 novices sir
quite substantial yeah he cannot really
play c5 as the same and now I'm d7 and
those pieces they don't have any squares
night cannot move rent the bishop yeah i
just put this only five
can easily improve the pajama rooks is
some the next step
one problem is of course that the night
only three is only protecting b5 and not
doing anything anything else let's see
that some way to to improve 90 summer
maybe is going 97 here what ought to god
this smells yeah setting up the knight
c6 idea so now I think he has no move
really knight c6 II can take with the
bishop our way this is actually really
aimed because I've got not be five I've
got 95 this is very important Bishop
takes see ticket I've got 95 years no
move now now in my next move the c7 and
on king d 6 i've got 95 yeah that's it
she's having us deadly
on 98 maybe 95 is even more precise
yeah it doesn't matter really see
sadness is enough really black resigned
yeah there's no move simply as c 7 s
deadly I think it started with a 4 I
think here this is just a normal
position well why that best has a very
slight edge but around here he should
really avoid a form this is really a big
positional mistake allowing me to play
b5 intensifying the pressure this is now
really tricky can defend better of
course but around here very tough very
tough to play rook a7 is a better
defense the computer gives that move
that is true this is a check okay seven
again off if the other computer has an
interesting suggestion look night AC
phone also good you can't didn't see
that but it gives Roxy semanas is even
stronger this is the sisters deadly yeah
here it also gives III tank okay ah ok
because of night xe6 him okay I
understand I had forgotten this this
defense of possibility it should win for
white but he can play on and while this
is immediately immediately losing yeah
the real deal is a form the real problem
giving me this additional option after
b4 and b5 alright thanks for watching